[Music]
you got a mock neck on it's working we
like it ready for it Bubba here we go
before we get started I want to share
some exciting news every year there's a
leading figure in journalism who is
presented with the prestigious Walter
Cronkite award for excellence in
journalism from Arizona State University
the list of past recipients includes Bob
Woodward Diane Sawyer Lester Holt
Anderson Cooper just sitting a handful
and now adding to that list is our own
Mrs King
it's going to be the 39th recipient of
the distinguished award congratulations
congratulations
this is a big deal I I know it's sort of
sinking in David I have to say when they
when I when they first told me I go
really I'm going to be in that class I'm
very honored to all be gone Monday and
Tuesday I'll be in Arizona hanging out
at Arizona State University I'm looking
forward to starting in this business did
you think that you would get this far
and now be recognized no no I was going
to do this for five six maybe eight
years and have children and then you
know I decided I was gonna you know
raise my kids and then life got in the
way so things turned out exactly the way
that they should and the cool thing for
me I tell people is you're just as great
off camera as you are on oh thank you
love about you number 39. just think
that I'm in the same name with Walter
Cronkite as well exactly that's what I
keep thinking that's incredible all
right
I got you girl good if you've watched
baseball at any time in the last few
decades you should recognize this
unmistakable voice
[Applause]
[Music]
get a lot of broken bad hits in the
shallow Outfield
the shallow part of the Outfield that's
the danger in bringing the infield in
with a guy like Rivera on the mound
foreign
Carver predicting the base hit that won
the 22 2001 World Series for the Arizona
Diamondbacks the former All-Star Catcher
And Hall of Fame broadcaster died
yesterday you know he won the World
Series with the St Louis Cardinals back
in 94 in 1964 and 67 McCarver was one of
the few Major Leaguers to play in four
different decades he retired in 1980 and
moved to the broadcast Booth McCarver
called 24 world series on CBS and other
networks that is more than any other
analyst baseball commissioner Rob
Manfred called him one of the most
influential voices our game has ever
known Mr Carver was 81 years old I was
sad to hear that yesterday I actually
remember him his voice is really
synonymous yeah and when you're a
broadcaster at that level you were
bringing in the next generation of fans
with your every utterance yes funny as
well he was he said good sense of humor
yeah speaking of golf uh Tiger Woods is
playing his first competitive tournament
in seven months and he had a pretty
thrilling Finish Well if you saw this it
happened at the Genesis in station in
Los Angeles after a rough start
yesterday Woods made three birdies on
the last three holes to shoot two under
par in the first round now that puts him
five shots behind the leaders wood says
his right ankle is still pretty sore
after that devastating car crash two
years ago and he is still making some
adjustments
my ankle's a lot smaller than it has
been so
I've had so many surgeries that uh the
the ankles just keeps changing the leg
keeps changing so
yes it the the shoes keep changing the
socks keep changing everything is a
moving Target
and continuing with golf Millions watch
the Masters on CBS every year as you
know but not a lot of people get to go
but you can pretend to be there with
what's called The Taste of the Masters
hosting kit you want to throw a party
watch some golf with your friends okay
like you're there the kid has all the
tournaments classic Foods okay you got
your classic egg salad or I like that
pimento cheese to make sandwiches with
there's also pork barbecue chips cookies
souvenir cups to serve your chosen cold
beverage now if you want to enjoy this
by April 6th when the 87th Masters
tournament airs here on CBS or Paramount
plus you have to pre-order it at
tasteofthemasters.com and I think
millions of people are going to do it
this looks very good but what I really
want is the flowers in my yard like
Masters and I want Jim Nance answering
the door and welcome welcome people into
the party yeah listen and these are so
cheap and the ticket might cost you a
few thousand bucks but these are like a
buck 50. the Silver Box yeah good food
Hey listen have a few drinks uh it's
been fun with you guys for the last few
weeks our man Vlad is back on Monday
David we appreciate you thank you so
much uh David doing what to watch a
tradition like no other